ABCs of AI H is for human in the loop
human in the loop or hitl is a machine
Learning System that involves human
input at some stage of the AI
development process though you may
assume machine learning systems are
fully automated there are several
scenarios where humans can provide more
accurate information in context when
making important decisions this includes
data labeling model development model
deployment as well as interactive
decision making human in the loop can be
used in a variety of applications as
well common examples include medical
diagnosis content moderation Customer
Service fraud detection self-driving
cars and many more scenarios where human
interaction and review can provide
improved accuracy enhanced safety and
more flexibility check out the links in
our description for more resources and
let us know what topics you want to
learn more about on the next episode of